So we've now created all of the individual assets that we're going to need for our chaos vehicle system
All that's left to do is to combine them together inside the vehicle blueprint and that's going to be the sort of parent for everything
So it's going to be the thing that combines all of this information together to give you your final output
It's going to be what you reference in the level and ultimately what you'll be driving around the scene
So let's take a look at making that now. The first step is going to be creating our blueprint
So back in the engine here right-click
come up to blueprint class and
Here we're going to search under the all classes heading and we're going to look for
wheel wheeled vehicle porn
And this is going to be our parent class and then we'll rename this
BP underscore
chaos
vehicle
Let's also put an underscore there to match the animation blueprint
And if I double click that to open up and just dock it inside the window there
We need to first tell the blueprint which skeletal mesh we want to be using
so under the components tab here, we're going to choose our mesh and
Under the skeletal mesh asset inside the details panel
We can if you've got a lot you can have a search for your your skeletal mesh
But because we've only got the one here we can just select that straight away
And you can see that we've got that inside our blueprint now
Now we need to tell it to use the animation blueprint that we just sent up as the anim class
so
With the the mesh selected still inside the details panel again
There's an anim class heading here and we're going to search for the ABP chaos vehicle
Animation blueprint that we created
so now the blueprint knows which vehicle we're talking about which skeletal mesh we're talking about and
It's using the correct animation blueprint that we set up just just earlier
Now we want to reference in the wheel blueprints that we set up right at the beginning
So coming over to the vehicle movement component inside the components tab
And there are a lot of different options here
And this is where you'd set up all sorts of stuff for your for your vehicle like your sort of engine setup
Your wheel setup any transmission gears things like that all sorts of stuff inside here that really help yourself tweak and customize the vehicle
But to get the wheel blueprints referenced and it's under the wheel setup drop down here and under wheel setups here
So because we have four wheels, I'm going to add four elements to this array. And if I just pop each of those open
you'll see that it's looking for a wheel class and by default it will have the
the sort of parent class that we we built our wheel blueprints off and
But you can see that as we open this up. We've got the wheel front and the wheel rear blueprints that we made
So for two of these I'm going to says wheel front and two of them
I'm going to set as wheel rear now
The only other thing we need to do here is set the bone names that these wheels will be referencing
So you need to make sure that you get this correct in terms of spelling and in terms of case
So I'm going to select our vehicle mesh and browse to the asset and if I just open that up
we should be able to access our skeleton tree here and
If I select one of our wheel bones wheel front are I can right-click this and copy the bone name
So that I know I won't be making any mistakes
if I come back to our wheel blueprint select our movement component again and in either of the
The front wheel classes if I just open this up a little bit and either of these top two
I can paste that bone name and hit enter and I'll do the same here, but change it to an L
or our front L and
I'm going to do the same for the rear wheels here
So if I just copy the formatting of our at the top then L on the bottom
I do L here and
R there
Our vehicle blueprint is now using our wheel blueprints with our custom settings
And we've linked them to the correct wheel bones as well just with the bone names inside here
So the next step would be to reference in our torque curve and set the max RPM for our vehicle
So with the vehicle movement component still selected
we'll scroll down in the details panel and under the mechanical setup, you have your torque curve here and
with the drop-down we'll reference in the torque curve that we created and
Because we set our max RPM to be 5,000
We're just going to match that in the settings here by setting that up and if I just compile and save
We're now pulling all of that information into this one blueprint from all of those individual assets that were created
So the wheel blueprints the animation blueprint
The torque curve all of those things are going to work together to to create our vehicle arc our chaos vehicle
So with all of these assets referenced in the last thing we need to do is actually enable physics on our blueprint itself on the mesh
Otherwise all of this work is not going to get calculated and nothing's going to happen because the blueprints not being told to actually
simulate the physics
so if we select our mesh here or
BP chaos vehicle
we can scroll down and
We can under the the physics heading check the simulate physics option box here
and that means it's now going to use all the information that we're feeding into it to calculate the physics of the vehicle and
Generate the the movement of the car itself
The last step is going to be adding a camera to our blueprint
So that when we're driving around we can actually see our vehicle and to do that. We need to add a couple of new components
So in the components tab up here if we have the mesh selected and
Then hit the add button whatever we add now with the mesh selected will add as a child to that mesh
so we're going to search for a spring arm and
With that selected we'll hit add again and we're going to search for a camera
so the spring arm will essentially just represent a pivot point for the camera and
something for the camera to follow and then the camera is what we're going to be using to
It's basically be our viewport for when we're controlling the car
You can customize this to look how you want, but we found these settings work pretty well
So we have a target arm length of 600
I'm just going to bring that camera a little further back and we're going to offset a socket by 250
So that it's just a bit higher up and we're going to turn off do collision test
We're also going to turn off inherit roll and that just means and the camera won't roll as
the car does which means you probably just get a little bit less motion sickness and it just looks a little nicer and
we're also going to make sure enable camera lag is turned on just to make things a little smoother basically and
In the camera settings themselves. I'm just going to add a little bit of rotation
to the the y-axis and I believe this is
Minus 10
There we go. So that's everything connected up now, which means our vehicle should be working
But we can't test it yet without some controls. So that's what we'll take a look at setting up next